un mélange de colère et de tristesse
contenue dans cette église pour rendre
hommage une dernière fois à Carry
necrose 29 ans battu à mort par des
policiers le 7 janvier dernier une
colère une blessure profonde parce qu'en
plus les policiers étaient tous à froids
américains
[Musique]
dans la ville où Martin Luther King a
perdu la vie dit-il vous avez tué un des
nôtres il n'y a rien de plus insultant
et offensant
[Applaudissements]
vous ne l'auriez pas battu à mort les
mots du révérend résonnent dans la salle
et pour beaucoup quelle que soit le
policier la victime est souvent noire
[Musique]
un chant telle une lamentation Tiphanie
rusher la tenue à être là pour la
famille Nikos elle aussi a perdu son
fils et après d'un an sous les balles de
la police au Texas les histoires se
ressemblent tragiquement mais cette fois
les policiers ont été renvoyés inculpées
et incarcérés 20 jours après la mort de
tahini calls
entre nous dit-il on réclame justice
rapide stevente et Clarke a perdu son
frère de 22 ans à Sacramento en 2018
on a eu une entente financière dit-il
mais le policier travaille toujours on
n'a jamais eu justice
réclame une réforme policière une fois
pour toute
je demande au congrès de passer le
projet de loi Josh Floyd sur la réforme
policière dit-elle et ses non nég
[Musique]
à l'extérieur même fils et morose à
l'image de l'humeur ambiante une pluie
verglaçante à paralysé la ville qui
porte le fardeau de la ville où Martin
Luther King a été assassiné il y a près
de 55 ans
le rêve de Martin Luther King a viré au
cauchemar dit-il
John Carroll lui s'est fait arrêter au
Mississipi parce que ses lumières
clignotaient
de la gomme dit-il est-ce que c'est
parce que je voulais masquer mon haleine
il a finalement libéré après une
batterie de test à l'intérieur un nain
les frères et soeurs de tarir Nichols
lui a rendu hommage
il faut que ce projet doit passe
dit-elle sinon ils auront tous du sang
sur les mains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gens qui te finalement l'église avec
le sentiment amer qui vont revivre
d'autres tragédies ici Radio-Canada
Memphis